I've taken a screen shot from
our fill in the blank proof
exercises.
And I'm going to work it out,
essentially, on digital paper.
And then we can fill in the
blanks on the actual exercise.
So they tell us that
BC is parallel to DF.
The figure is not drawn
to scale-- fair enough.
Then they tell us that angle
CEF is congruent to angle BAC.
CEF, so that's this
right over here.
CEF is congruent to BAC.
So it's congruent
to that over there.
Then they tell us that
CFE is congruent to ABC.
Angle CFE is congruent
to angle ABC.
Then they tell us that
segment CF is congruent to BC.
BDE is congruent to ACB.
So that's that right over there.
Then they tell us DE
is congruent to AC.
And then finally, they
tell us that-- let
me do that in a
different color--
so BED is congruent to BAC.
Let me make sure I get it.
BED-- so it's this
angle right over here--
is congruent to BAC.
BAC is this blue one
over there, so we already
have a marker for that.
So I'll write the blue
one just like that.
So that's that piece
of information as well.
Now we're ready for the proof.
Now whenever you
do any proof, it's
good to know what
you're trying to prove.
So let's just cut
to the chase and see
where this proof actually goes.
So in the last
statement of the proof,
they say triangle BCA is
congruent to triangle BCE
because-- and we
have to figure out
why we can say that
based on everything
that this proof has
proven beforehand.
But so we're
essentially just proving
that triangle BCA, which is this
triangle right up here-- this
is BCA-- that it is
congruent to triangle BCE.
BCE is this triangle-- this
downward-pointing triangle.
So this is what we're
trying to prove.
This is congruent to
that right over here.
This triangle is congruent
to that triangle.
So that's important
to keep in mind.
And all we know about
these two triangles
is it they share a
side in common, which
is equal to itself by
the reflexive property.
But we don't have any
other information.
We're going to have to figure
out whether other sides are
congruent or maybe other
angles or something else
in order to actually
make this statement.
So let's see what they've
done in the proof.
So first they make a statement.
And we don't need to
correct it, but it's
good to follow the
narrative of their proof.
BCA is congruent to BDE
because of angle, side, angle.
So let's see, we have an
angle, side, angle; angle,
side, angle.
This triple arc corresponds to
D here, corresponds to C there.
And you see that even over here.
The way they wrote it,
D is the middle here,
and C is the middle there.
So they do correspond
to each other.
That makes sense.
This side, DE, should
correspond to CA.
And you see that over here.
DE corresponds to CA based
on the order it's written.
E comes right after D.
A comes right after C.
And angle E should correspond
to angle A, and it does.
Angle E corresponds to
angle A, and it does.
So this is completely
legitimate-- angle, side,
angle; angle, side, angle
It's a little bit hard
based on how they're oriented.
It would've been easier if they
were oriented in the same way.
But this is legitimate.
By angle, side, angle, these
two triangles are congruent.
Then they say, something
is equal to something
because corresponding parts
of congruent triangles
are congruent.
And this is a little bit
harder because they're probably
making a statement-- we just
proved that this triangle
right over here is congruent
to this triangle up here.
And so if we're going to say
that two corresponding things
are congruent, it's probably
two corresponding things
in these two triangles.
And what is corresponding
in these two triangles that
will help us get to
our end goal of saying
that this top triangle is
congruent to this bottom one?
Well the only information that
this side triangle right over
here, that BDE shares with the
central triangle is this side.
So maybe we can say that this
side corresponds to some side
up here.
And it does because
they're congruent.
And then that'll
give us information
for this middle triangle.
So let's just think about that.
And it may or may not be right,
but it's a good working guess.
And there's different
ways to tackle these.
So this side over here, if
we look at how this is-- BE
should correspond to BA.
BE-- and remember,
it's between the blue
and the not triple green side.
So these two should
correspond based
on the information
right over here.
Let me do this in
a different color.
This thing should be congruent
to that thing right over there.
And that gives us
interesting information
because now we've built
up two congruent sides
of this middle one
and this top one.
So let's write
that as our working
thesis of what they want here.
So we can say BE-- well, we
could say the length is equal--
but we could even say
BE is congruent to BA
because corresponding parts
of congruent triangles
are congruent.
And this is not an
easy thing to do.
But the real hint
is they just told us
that these two
things are congruent.
And we want some information
about this middle triangle.
And they share a
common side here.
So it seems reasonable enough.
Hopefully that gets us
to the right end point.
Now they tell us that triangle
BCA is congruent to FCE.
And we started at F.
We started at B. That's
the double angle side.
Then you went across
this one side,
and you went across this
side with the magenta marker.
So that seems right because
of angle, angle, side.
Angle, angle, side--
angle, the blue angle,
double magenta angle, and then
this single, magenta slash
side.
Angle, angle, side--
angle, angle, side.
That seems legitimate,
and it should
unless there was some type
of error in this code.
And then they say AC
is congruent to CE
because-- well we just figured
out that this top triangle is
congruent to this
one down over here.
So it's probably going to be
because of corresponding sides
of congruent triangles.
And we can verify it.
If this is congruent to
that, then let's see,
AC is between the blue angle
and the non-magenta angle.
And EC is between the blue
angle and the non-magenta angle.
I haven't marked it here.
And so we have AC is
indeed congruent to CE.
And now this is interesting,
and this was useful
because this shared a side
with this middle triangle
that we care about.
And so we now show that this
top triangle, all the sides
have the same lengths as
all the sides down here.
So this was actually
useful information
that we figured out, so I
think that was the right way
to go about it.
Oh, I need to finish this.
AC is congruent to CE
because corresponding parts
of corresponding angles.
Let me write it in black.
And when we actually
fill it in, there
will be a pull-down--
so corresponding parts.
And then finally, we're
in the home stretch.
We're ready to say that
BCA, this top triangle,
is congruent to triangle BCE.
All their sides are the same.
So this is side,
side, side congruency.
So now let's verify our answer.
So let's take out
the actual exercise.
And so let's go down here.
The first thing I want to type
in is that BE is equal to BA.
So let me type that in,
BE-- and if this is right,
it'll actually just process
it-- is equal to BA.
And it is.
There you go.
Segment BE is congruent AB.
So that's how we know
we've got that right.
I wrote it as BA, but
that's the same thing.
And that's why it processed it.
And then AC is congruent to CE
because of corresponding parts.
There you go.
And then finally,
these two triangles
are congruent because of
side, side, side congruence.
And now let's verify our answer.
I feel good about it, and I
am ready to check my answer.
Yes, it is correct.